Also hier ist eine Frage zur Lotterie mit Common.
Okay, das hört sich ziemlich beängstigend an, aber ich
schätze, ich wähle die richtige Farbe. Ja, du kannst
wählen. Die roten Fragen sind wirklich unangenehme
Fragen für dich und die grünen sind
harmlos, aber sie passen perfekt zu deiner Farbe,
weißt du was?  Ich werde
langsam anfangen und mich für Komfort entscheiden und dann
für Grün, okay, okay, das stimmt, ich
stimme zu, okay, interessant, okay,
ich bin nervös, ich bin nervös, ich bin nervös, ich bin
ein bisschen nervös, aber es ist ein guter Monat,
also ist es ja  Okay, okay, sicher, okay, was
hier kannst du lesen, was das Geheimnis
deines Erfolgs ist, na ja, ich kann dir sagen, ich bin
der einzige singende, tanzende, redende Frosch
und Showbusiness,
okay, wie kann ich nicht erfolgreich sein? Ich habe
keine Konkurrenz,
das ist also ein Markt, Vater von dir  Weißt du, was
das war, das war so einfach, ich denke, ich würde
gerne ein rotes nehmen, okay, ich denke, ich
sollte ein rotes nehmen, gut, ja,
also
ein rotes, ja, ja, also habe ich es hier, wir
gehen, es ist ein rotes
böse, oh ja, du wirst es sehen, ja, ja,
ja, wann wirst du Miss Piggy
heiraten?  Ich habe
tatsächlich vor, Miss Piggy zu heiraten, weil
wir seit ungefähr 35 Jahren zusammen sind,
aber ähm, ich weiß nicht, ob ein Frosch und
ein Schwein tatsächlich heiraten können oder nicht.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob das legal ist,
okay, du weißt, das stimmt, ja, du.  Ich habe
Recht, also bin ich dabei.
Okay, ja, okay, also letzte Frage, rot oder
grün. Oh, lass uns einfach Rot nehmen, okay, ja,
letztes Rot, Rot, Rot, komm schon, komm
schon, ja, es ist
alles in Ordnung, ich bin nur alt  Alter, zappelig,
also hier, okay, das ist wirklich schlimm, oh, deine
Stimme kreischt so. Ja, warum
singst du mit dieser Stimme, oh, weil es die
einzige ist, die ich habe,
okay,
also können wir jetzt einen Kreischwettbewerb veranstalten,
okay, ja, warum machen wir das nicht, okay?  Ich
habe ähm The Rainbow Connection gespielt.
Das würde ich gerne mit dir machen